hey bobo what's up i heard you were
freaking out hey now howard yeah i
thought you forgot about me
i've been here on the board every day i
know with the same question i see it
no i have all kinds of questions i have
about 18 legal pads that i'm staring at
i'm stuck that i have keeping my brain
but you think when the guy who invented
the legal pad imagining that one day
bobo would be the guy who called into
the show and filled up endless legal
pads with questions nobody cares about
you really have 18 legal pads with
questions possible questions
i took a picture i have my stuff all
over the place because there's so many
topics in my head you know i had the kim
kardashian i want to talk about snl
monologue i thought it was so great
kudos to the writers over there by the
way you know and i like how's that a
question though
why is he calling
saturday night live
my problem with bobo's questions it's
almost like saying to me hey howard i'm
gonna throw out the name kim kardashian
in saturday night live and then you can
make something of it
no there is he just wants to bring up a
topic basically yeah i enjoyed the
sketches i liked all of that and i
thought she was really spot on you know
hi
by the way i've got 19 more wiggle pads
here with other ideas in case you're not
crazy about the kim kardashian question
or statement or whatever it is that i'm
saying okay
oh howard here we go howard
robin and howard 9 11 9 12 9 13 thoughts
yeah your thoughts what by the way real
boba what what is on that legal page i
put this together on fred trivia game
and it's probably stuff you guys don't
even know about are you aware that fred
has appeared in nine feature films could
you name them i don't think fred could
name him honestly i don't think he could
either your thoughts i never heard fred
you know bring up these films that he
was then cruel intentions two tickets to
paradise all in time cold hearts
lemasters lulu on the bridge
he was in a lot of stuff
fred for a while was doing some film
work and uh what do you want to know
about well
i came what do you want me again like
what radio station did fred work at
after wcc and offered lzx was it w-a-q-y
was it
wpbc it was wacky w-a-q-y yeah that's it
yeah that's it yeah your wife
you wanna hit me up with some more okay
uh where in connecticut was fred bourne
windham connecticut woman romantic or
norwich
when i'm when when am i man and anik oh
norwich
i don't even know what he said
by the way bobo you've given two correct
answers it's windham county and will
romantic connecticut so it's it's
windham okay your thoughts i mean only
fred could be born in two places at one
time
by the way you got to see the the bobo
puppet got a whole makeover like um what
what is that set there bobo puppet what
do you got there like it's uh are you in
a car you're in a car yeah cause i i
always have to call for my car because i
annoy the [ __ ] out of my wife so she
forces me to go outside so it's either
here or an alligator pit down by the uh
swamp so
this is this is my new set right here
and the bubble puppet has all the new
bobo facial hair and the facial facial
hair that comes stain underneath my whip
it's it's great you know what i got to
tell you something bobo puppet you are
way more interesting than the real bobo
honestly
thank you